if you measured good and evil deeds by
current laws then I would be responsible
for many crimes that's why I only take
on cases that piqued my interest
it's not about justice at and if it
means being able to clear a case then I
don't play fair hello and welcome to
Death Note 101 the series that breaks
down everyone and everything in the
Death Note world today we are going to
be taking a look at the fan-favorite
insomniac detective with a mind that can
change the world hell L real name L low
light is a world-renowned detective who
chose to take on the Kira case and as a
result act simultaneously as the hero as
well as primary antagonist of Death Note
initially comes across as kind of an
oddball even amongst this huge cast of
unique characters which the series has
to offer with Earl's most recognizable
characteristics including his iconic
sitting posture and ever monotonous
clothing choices that consist ple of
white long-sleeve shirts and old jeans
very much evoke in that whole a
disheveled genius chic but that said L
doesn't generally care what other people
think of him and he often says exactly
what comes to mind without thinking of
the feelings of the person on the
receiving end but of course else crown
and characteristic is his immense
intellect and meticulously analytical
approach to life in fact it has been
said by Sukhumi Oba that L is the most
intelligent character in the entire
series and using his brilliant acumen he
is capable of outsmarting and
manipulating his opponents with his
profound understandings of the
mechanisms of the human mind furthermore
in this effort L isn't afraid to lie
cheat or do pretty much anything that
could guarantee his victory to the point
where Oba has even stated that he
considers L to be a little evil because
of this sector of his personality and to
add to this L himself has even admitted
that he is quite childish and despises
the very concept of losing as far as
Elle's backstory goes most of the
information we have available comes in
the form of two one-shot manga chapters
those being held the wammy's house and L
one day where it is revealed that his
detective career started at an
incredibly young age where after he was
taken into an orphanage for gifted
children L immediately began showing
interest in problem-solving and even
rather rapidly making the leap from
jigsaw puzzles to successfully investing
in the stock market as he going lad L
also went on to spend most of his time
sitting in front of his computer however
he also happened to possess a great deal
of physical prowess as he was able to
beat up multiple children of his age in
an all against one fight and after doing
so he simply stated what he had just
done was justice after some time L
stumbled upon a newspaper article
stating that a particular
case was more difficult to solve than
any puzzle or game and 12 L being L the
challenge was accepted and L would
successfully discover the criminal whom
the police hadn't found any leads
regarding by using only the mighty power
of the internet following this quilling
family poured all of his efforts and
resources into giving L everything he
needed in order to pursue this new hobby
as L grew older he started developing a
very close relationship with Polish as
well forming a strong partnership with
him in the field of detective Rhee and
even coming to see him as something of a
father figure as the pair moved on to
more difficult cases foolish took on the
alias of watery and worked as a mediator
between L and the police around the
world guerrilla shows have performed
significantly more simple tasks such as
washing his clothes taking him out to
have fun and other assorted general
parenting with this in mind during the
course of the series foolish is one of
the only people that L has shown genuine
care towards the two of them were
practically inseparable one remarkable
case they took on before the start of
the series was a Los Angeles BB murder
case in which L required the help of
Naomi Masada in order to catch a child
from wammy's house who had started
murdering people in order to challenge L
directly at this point wammy's house had
evolved from being a simple orphanage
for gifted children to an institution in
which Quilici was conducting a search
for possible successes for L this was
because L now had such a prestigious
reputation for figuring out crimes
thought to be unsolvable that his mere
existence was enough to prevent many
people from even thinking of committing
crimes and therefore if L were to die
the crime rate was hypothesized to
increase significantly throughout the
world and this brings us to the Kira
case when criminals around the world
started mysteriously dying of heart
attacks the international police were at
a loss of what to do however once L
stepped in he was swiftly able to prove
Kira's existence as well as even
pinpoint his location to the Kanto
region of Japan or within a single plan
of action concerning a fake worldwide
broadcast and in fact this plan is what
really highlights the idea that L lives
in a morally gray area as for it to work
he willingly sacrifice the life of a
death-row prisoner which I suppose yes
you could argue that he was going to die
anyway but ELLs like a value for life
actually comes strikingly close to
reflecting lights philosophy of criminal
lives but after having confirmed the
existence of Kira Eldon relocated to
Japan and created the Japanese task
force a group who would serve as the
main challenger to the mysterious mass
murderer in regards to the individuals
of this task force despite their close
working relationship L essentially saw
them in the same way that he did all
other humans and was often irritated by
their action
sometimes time and of course vice versa
the exception to this came in the form
of Soichiro Yagami whom L showed great
respect towards from the very beginning
due to his sheer amount of dedication
and strong sense of justice whilst
working with this task force we were
also introduced to Elle's iconic love
for sweets as he enjoys all kinds of
sugary treats to the point where he even
drinks coffee with such a staggering
amount of sugar cubes that it really
should be more accurately considered
throwing in some coffee
with his sugar cubes it is said that L
does this because sugar makes his brain
work faster which happens to be a
similar explanation that he gives for
his unusual sitting posture claiming
that if he sits in any other way then
his reasoning ability drops by around
40% after the death of 12 FBI agents at
the hands of Kira it didn't take long
for L to start suspecting the genius
high-school student Light Yagami who
very swiftly became his primary suspect
and here we have a fantastic example of
Elle's tendency to you know ignore the
law when it prevents him from solving a
case as he proceeded to play 64 yes 64
surveillance cameras in Light Yagami
small bedroom without his knowledge in
order to get some sort of visual
confirmation of his killings of course
during this time under observation light
did nothing majorly suspicious which
oddly enough only made him even more
suspicious to L Elven decided to perform
a gambit and show his face to light but
not only that because L then even
invited him to join the Kira task force
in an effort to bring him closer to his
primary suspect the relationship that
then went on to develop between L and
Wyatt is complicated to say the least as
far as we know light did not think of L
as anything than a rival and an enemy
now have L stated that light is the
first friend that he has ever had
although the validity of that statement
is up in the air because urbe has stated
that L is a liar and another example of
that would be when he says that there is
a 5% chance that light is Kira no
actually means that that chance is more
along the lines of 95% so take anything
that he says with a huge grain of salt
now after joining the task force the
ever-popular light started quote-unquote
dating multiple girls
amongst to him was a 19 year old actress
named Misa Amane and after investigating
her he'll quickly found to finish if
proof that she was the second Kira
shortly after L had both Misa and light
arrested and in the beginning while
sabor in custody the killings came to a
stop which confirmed to L once and for
all that light was Kira and that Misa
was acting under his direction however
the case wouldn't quite be that simple
as following this line and Misa started
acting in a strange manner in clay
that they had no recollection being Kira
and the second care respectively and
crazily enough a few days later the kira
murders resumed whilst the two was still
in custody
l was then forced to release both Misa
and light after which he asked a latter
to join the task force again although he
still believed that they were indeed the
first and second Kira and that they had
simply lost their memories which he know
is pretty damn on the money actually and
this is why he is the smartest character
in the series however as a result l
would experience an uncharacteristic
bout of depression due to his lack of
progress that led him to cease actively
working on the Kira case for months on
end and oddly enough would be primary
suspects Light Yagami who would be the
one to literally knock L back to his
senses showing that the two had actually
developed quite a legitimate friendship
and when L does return to the case he
and light are quickly able to find and
capture the third Kira a man named
Kirksey huger a solution that leaves l
greatly underwhelmed
however after who Gucci's capture L lays
his hands on a Death Note for the first
time which allows him to see the
Shinigami RAM and while he is initially
shocked L ends up taking the sudden
existence of Shinigami quite well I'd
say he does face a problem however as
there was a fake rule written in the
Death Note that could exonerate light
which stated that if a person does not
write again in a Death Note after 13
days than they will be killed
remaining ever vigilant l decided to
test if that rule does in fact work
however before he could do this both he
and watery were killed by REM who had
been manipulated by a light and as L
died of a heart attack in lights arms
but provided a simple smug look intended
to inform him that he had indeed been
Kira the entire time but this would not
be the end of L as after his death two
children from wammy's house were
informed of what had happened and they
set out to defeat kira once and for all
and to continue Elle's legacy some more
fun facts about L l was essentially
designed to be the complete opposite of
light for example while light adorns
himself in nice bothing l chooses to don
old jeans and everyday shirts and to
where light is well-mannered l walks
around barefoot and bites his
fingernails in polite company
apparently Oh Burt I even made him
purposely look less attractive although
I feel like there's a whole dejan of
people out there who would dispute that
outcomes l was originally supposed to be
a little older actually however Oba felt
that the story would not have worked as
well if L had been visibly older than
his adversary light when a character in
the death night animation thinking
something their hair turns a specific
color which in Al's case is blue a color
that traditionally represents traits
such as intuition imagination confidence
or
and intelligence when questioned about
ELLs genetic background over responded
that he thinks of him as a quarter
Japanese a quarter English a quarter
Russian and a quarter of either French
or Italian and if take big before obba
settled on Elle's name he considered
other letters out of which close
contenders what I and J and finally a
truly useless fact when thinking
intensely helped refers to either bite
the nail of his thumb or press his thumb
against his lower lip that pretty much
does it for L if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produced in
general and please do consider donating
to the new world review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your start then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps spot this channel
an incredible amount and if you'd like
to join the fun at any time then please
do head over to my discord server where
a wide array of shenanigan retakes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with who what aware you'd like
to see featured in the next death note
101
a plan to capture carry you say well
that's easy step one identify Kiera step
to invite Kiera to help hunt Kiera step
three
banana step full everyone lives happily
ever after
Elle you've done it again